hey guys it's pete peppers with candy
crush saga saga tips calm and this is a
candy crush soda level 85 walkthrough
with some commentary this is a regular
old chocolate level that it's a tough
one because you have this bottleneck in
between the top part of the board in the
bottom part one thing that is nice is
that the pieces do fall from the top to
the bottom so you know you can make like
a raft plus a color bomb combo or
something like that and the pieces will
fall down won't all get stuck at the top
like in some of the other levels so the
main thing is making specials and then
using them in ways that will open up the
bottom as fast as possible so in this
case you know we'll make this rap to
match it with the coloring candy and
that should help I mean most of them are
still at the top but there's no real
reason I don't think to wait there just
go ahead and start because that gets us
going into the bottom half one of the
things I always try to do when I'm
playing difficult chocolate levels like
this is I try to I try to keep the
growth under control but at the same
time always look above for combos up
there because you know if one piece of
candy grows but we set up a combo that's
going to take out a lot of them then
that's a good trade-off and fish plus
strike two really good in this because
they'll go down and clear out some space
and also double wrap so be really good
too because they blow up such a big big
amount of area so let's see we have
20 moves left just plenty but as you
know the chocolate can keep grow and so
we definitely have to be careful I think
here this is one of those spots where I
can go up top I can maybe make drop this
blue here and see if we can get a color
bomb and we did so you're just going to
want to you know try to do stuff like
that then I'll go to the bottom and hit
the chocolate a couple times to make
sure that it doesn't get too out of
control the color bottom up there will
hopefully make its way down and we'll be
able to match it with something but
since we have 14 moves and we're down
just to the last two roses it's it's
probably a good idea for us to stay
towards the bottom right now click here
we commence the yellow on the right hand
side and I will drop it that will hit
the chocolate and drop the color bomb
same with the green right here so now
we'll just see if we can't match it up
with something and we got lucky and got
a color bomb at the top I think here we
just used to take one of the colors out
the yellow will hit the chocolate a
little bit but also moving all those
yellows out at the bottom gives us more
of a chance to create specials and
combos and here this is this is going to
clear out everything except for that one
in the corner so all we'll need to do is
try to make a match and we can match
this red right here so that's basically
the thing you want to do hit the
chocolate look for combos look for
things towards the bottom of the board
that you can send vertically like I said
fish + strike two good double wraps are
good and obviously you're not going to
get to you know beat it every single
time but if you can get down pretty
quickly through the middle and then
start to plan things out you should get
it within a few tries hope this helps I
for someone in my group and I hope that
will help them get past please like the
video and subscribe to our channel so
you'll know when we have new videos
coming out and I'll talk to you soon